des étudiants de la résidence océane à
schoelcher inquiète
l'une d'entre elles a été transporté
lundi dernier aux urgences du chu
picasso braque hitman ramène à car elle
souffrait de maux de ventre après avoir
consommé l'eau du robinet des cartels
j'ai bu l'eau du rhône et l indien je
n'ai rien remarqué de particulier mais
mon ami avait une odeur bizarre la vie
j'ai décidé de ne plus boire l'eau
j'ai été malade quand même à fort de
france hier je ne sais pas ce qui se
passe je pense que c'est l'eau il n'y a
pas d'autre explication
je n'ai rien mangé de particulier je ne
comprends pas ce qui se passe depuis
lundi dernier
elles sont dérangés par de très fortes
émanations de gaz provenant du
rez-de-chaussée de l'immeuble qui a
complètement inondées une vraie passoire
les couloirs sont inondées mais c'est
vrai que particulièrement lundi on a
remarqué qu'il y avait déjà les pros la
première fois les pompiers qui étaient
venus pour le premier étage qui avait eu
ce problème d'inondation est aujourd'hui
eleven ils sont venus pour nous parce
qu'il ya vraiment sont quand même des
inondations en plus des odeurs de gaz
c'est de voir un pays en soi est
effectivement le lot et le coût d'une
mauvaise ou quoi on a eu des fumées de
des vapeurs d'eau toxique des gorges qui
brûlait des gens qui était asthmatique
aurait pu tomber gravement malade à
cause de ça d'autres qui ont bu l'eau
qui ne se sentent pas bien ce ne sont
pas des conditions en fait comme le
confirme le directeur du crous absent du
département un phénomène de surpression
du système d'eau chaude est à l'origine
de ce dysfonctionnement activement il ya
une coïncidence entre les problèmes que
cette étudiante a eu au 20ème également
que nous avons beau de des ballons d'eau
chaude et des canalisations qui est
supposé donc il ya certainement eu dans
les canalisations des résidus de cheetah
problèmes techniques
des mesures provisoires seront prises
dans l'attenté d'une réparation complète
j'ai tellement lesquels un affichage
d'urgence accompagnés d'étudiants ne
consomme pas l'eau l'eau du robinet et
qu'il y est
à écouter qu'ils soient distribués
jusqu'à la fed et pravo autres cette
défaillance du système d'eau chaude
cet immeuble conçu il ya peine dix ans
présentent de sérieux problèmes
d'étanchéité au niveau de la toiture
empêchant du coup l'exploitation des 97
appartements en parallèle aux expertises
engagé le centre national des oeuvres
universitaires et scolaires a prévu des
réparations en nos chances